yes sir i did have 32 hats i was ready
for anybody to pick me
and uh coach groom he definitely did
call me and
i'm in pensacola florida i'm on the
beach it's my hometown and i was
surrounded by my uh
friends and family and uh i couldn't
hang them more for being him
for being here and supporting me and it
was a great overall experience and a
great drive
because as far as being a leader that
was definitely one thing that i wanted
to change about myself going from my
junior to my senior year
just uh trying to affect those around me
you know what i mean in a positive way
and always harping on the things that we
needed to do to be champions and uh
i feel like that went well by the
results of my senior season
i mean um to be honest uh it wasn't
really
overwhelming not that i wasn't excited
and extremely grateful
for the opportunity but um
you know i i controlled what i could
control you know what i mean so i was
ready for like any outcome i feel like i
did the best
i could do and when they called me and
when they called me i was calm
i was uh ready to go
as soon as i got a call i was like i
don't know who this is you know what i
mean but hey it's go
time you know what i mean so i was just
uh super grateful
elated at the opportunity and uh yeah
that's pretty much it